bonjour le sauna démarre cet après midi
l'examen du projet de loi destiné à
réduire la précarité dans la fonction
publique
ce texte vise selon le gouvernement à
obtenir de 40 à 50 milles titularisation
ainsi que la modification des contrats
de 100 mille agents de cdd en cdi alors
ce projet de loi eh bien il découle
directement d'un accord signé par six
syndicats représentatifs sur 8 accords
signés en mars 2011 après de longues
négociations le projet de loi fait
l'objet d'une procédure accélérée c'est
à dire qu'il n'y aura qu'une seule
lecture dans chaque assemblée le texte
viendra devant les députés à partir du 7
février prochain le chef de l'état a
notamment souhaité lors de ses voeux à
la fonction publique au début de ce mois
de janvier est bien que l'examen de ce
texte au parlement aboutisse très
rapidement donc tout de suite je vous
laisse rejoindre l'hémicycle du sénat
poursuivre la discussion générale autour
de ce projet de loi destiné à réduire la
précarité dans la fonction publique très
bonne séance à tout ça bien nous avons
nous allons passer à l'ordre du jour
dans la discussion générale la parole et
à monsieur françois sauvadet ministre de
la fonction publique
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente représentants présents de la
commission des lois
monsieur sueur madame rapporteur
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs le
projet de loi j'ai l'honneur de
présenter devant devant vous aujourd'hui
est le prolongement d'un accord syndical
qui vise à lutter contre la précarité
dans la fonction publique une forme de
précarité dont je veux dire et rappeler
qu'elle est souvent méconnue nos
concitoyens elle est d'autant plus
inacceptable en tout cas qu'elle prend
racine au coeur même de la république
c'est-à-dire dans nos services publics
dans nos administrations dans nos
collectivités dans nos hôpitaux
ce ne serait pas cette précarité frappe
aujourd'hui plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'agents contractuels de la
fonction publique employés avec des cdd
qui se renouveler parfois depuis des
années sur des emplois correspondant
pourtant un besoin permanent du service
public est le plus souvent d'ailleurs
sans aucune garantie pour leur avenir
ce projet de loi entend donc remédier
durablement à cette situation
une situation dont je voudrais rappeler
aussi devant donc elle n'est pas
nouvelle depuis 1946 il y a eu
pratiquement 16 plan de titularisation
le dernier remontant à 2001 l'objectif
pour nous est donc de mettre un terme je
reprends le mode durable à cette
situation
avant d'entrer dans le détail des
mesures je veux dire très clairement que
tous les agents contractuels de la
fonction publique ne sont pas confrontés
à des situations de précarité
nous devrons pour l'état dans nos
collectivités demain comme hier avoir la
possibilité de recourir à des agents
contractuels pour répondre à des besoins
temporaires des surcharges de travail
ponctuels des vacances d'emploi des
remplacements d'agents absents ou encore
à des besoins spécifiques
en revanche on ne peut pas accepter une
situation qui conduit des personnes à
rester en cdd depuis parfois plus d'une
dizaine d'années celle sens mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs des engagements
que nous avons pris en janvier 2010 et
qui ont été pris par le président de la
république des engagements réaffirmés
voici à peine quelques jours à ville
lors de ses voeux à la fonction publique
l'état ne peut pas s'exonérer lorsqu'il
est employeur des règles qu'il veut
faire respecter aux autres l'état se
doit d'être exemplaire dans sa gestion
est dans une période de crise telle que
celle que nous traversons et nous
appartient lui appartient de montrer la
voie nous allons demander je n'ignore
pas des efforts fonctionnaires des
efforts importants ils ont eu à faire
face à des mutations profondes pas
simplement d'ailleurs dans la fonction
publique d'état mais je crois dans
toutes les fonctions publiques dans les
trois versants
la société change la société évolue et
nous devons d'adressés aussi à tous ceux
qui travaillent dans la fonction
publique à tous les fonctionnaires un
signal fort de justice et d'équité
c'est aussi l'occasion de rappeler notre
attachement aux principes fondateurs de
la fonction publique
une fonction publique qui s'est bâtie
sur un principe énoncé dès 1789 par le
sixième article de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen celui de
l'égal accès de tous les citoyens aux
divers différents emplois publics et ce
jeu reprend les termes d'ailleurs du
texte lui-même et ce sans autre
distinction que celle de leurs vertus et
de leurs talents
c'est précisément cette ambition qui
étaient reprises à la libération dans le
statut de 1946 ce principe impose
je veux leur dire devant vous tous que
les emplois permanents de l'état des
collectivités des établissements publics
relevant de la fonction publique
hospitalière soit occupé par des
fonctionnaires ce principe c'est une
garantie incontestablement garanties
offertes à tous les citoyens d'abord
pour leur permettre un égal accès à des
missions de service public à la fonction
publique et aux emplois publics mais
aussi garantit la neutralité et
l'impartialité des services de l'état et
de l'ensemble des collectivités
publiques
c'est également je veux le souligner une
spécificité du modèle français de
service public à laquelle nous sommes
tous peut le dire attaché ce principe
fondamental n'a pas été pour autant
d'applications absolue et dès 1946 je
veux aussi de rappeler le législateur a
ouvert aux employeurs publics la
possibilité d'y déroger pour recourir à
des agents contractuels n'ayant donc pas
le statut de fonctionnaire
qu'il s'agisse pour répondre à des
besoins temporaires ou certains besoins
permanents du service public est
précisément pour assurer la continuité
du service public
les cas où il était possible de courir
au
contrat était alors très limitée la
place de l'emploi non titulaires dans
nos services publics ne devaient être
que résiduelles et métro font qu'une
exception dans le fonctionnement
quotidien de nos administrations
ce qu'on constate après bien des années
c'est que la place de l'emploi non
titulaires la place des agents
contractuels au sein de nos
administrations n'a eu de cesse de
s'accroître au fil des années malgré une
quinzaine de plan je vous disais 16 plan
de titularisation les agents non
titulaires sont aujourd'hui près de
900000 dans notre pays ne s'empilent
dans les trois versants soit un peu
moins de 17 % de l'ensemble des
effectifs de la fonction publique
donc je vous le disais sur ces neuf cent
mille cent mille sont sur des cdd
renouvelés depuis des années et donc dès
2010 le gouvernement engagé sur cette
question des emplois qui est précaire
une négociation avec des partenaires
sociaux au cours de ces négociations
nous avons recherché avec les
organisations syndicales
une ligne de partage une déquilibre pour
faire coïncider à la fois le respect du
statut de la fonction publique et à la
fois la lutte contre la précarité
je dois dans la confidence de vous dire
c'est pas un exercice facile
d'ailleurs j'observe adam le rapporteur
madame tasca que vous l'avez vous même
d'ailleurs souligné dans votre rapport
mais le souci du compromis la volonté
aussi d'avancer pour aider la situation
toutes ces personnes qui sont
confrontées à des difficultés dit avec
des cdd
je vous le disais j'ai eu des
témoignages poignants parfois depuis 12
ans 15 ans donc la volonté d'avancer
nous ont permis de conduire une
négociation que j'ose le mot de
qualifier d'exemplaire et qui s'est
inscrite pleinement dans le cadre du
dialogue social du nouveau dialogue
social issu de l'entrée en vigueur de la
loi du 5 juillet 2010 nous avons partagé
une volonté commune celle d'apporter des
réponses concrètes à ces situations je
le répète sans conduire à une remise en
cause du statut se sait que de
négociations s'est finalement conclue
par un protocole d'accord le 31 mars
dernier ce texte je veux leur dire aussi
devant vous a été signé par six
organisations syndicales sur 8 à la
vérité de dire c'est que les les deux
autres n'avaient pas obtenu dans le
règlement interne le nombre de voix
suffisantes pour engager leur
confédération
syndicats en tout cas il y avait là une
unanimité que je me permets de souligner
donc ce texte signé par six
organisations syndicales représentatives
a permis d'avancer et je veux vraiment
devant vous salué l'esprit de
responsabilité des organisations
syndicales qui ont tout fait pour
aboutir dans ces discussions
bon ça veut pas dire bien sûr je le dis
à madame le rapporteur que nous soyons
d'accord sur tout j'en ai bien
conscience
mais lorsqu'un accord propose des
assauts des avancées satisfaisantes
je répète des avancées satisfaisantes
pour chacun il importe et il nous
importe de le reconnaître tout
simplement et de s'engager
je veux rappeler que cet accord
constitue le quatrième accord qui a été
conclu depuis mai 2007 entre le
gouvernement et les organisations
syndicales et nous appartient désormais
de le traduire dans la loi de la
république
en clair l'administration sera tenu
si le texte est voté ce que je souhaite
sera tenu d'accorder un cdi aux agents
en cdd dès lors qu'ils auront exercé
pendant une durée minimale de six ans
sur les huit dernières années leurs
fonctions dans des postes d'emploi
permanents
donc ces choses sont claires au bout de
six ans sur les huit dernières années
quand un agent occuper un poste d'emploi
permanents on transforme sur cd ans son
cdd en cdi
je rappelle qu'en tout de même par
parenthèse que l'obligation est faite
dans le privé après 18 mois
donc là nous retranscrivons une
directive qui veut que nous mettions à
terme à ces situations qui n'a je le dis
de mon point de vue du point de vue du
gouvernement que trop duré alors cette
mesure bon sur les chiffres on pourrait
concerner madame le rapporteur à peu
près cent mille personnes
on a demandé qu'on me demandait
d'ailleurs lorsque j'ai rencontré des
groupes
le chiffre que ça pourrait concerner
environ cent mille personnes donc ce
n'est pas rien cent mille personnes qui
sont directement concernés je le répète
dans leur vie quotidienne
allez avec un cdd successifs rechercher
un logement recherché un prêt pour aller
pour acquérir un bien
c'est extraordinairement compliquée donc
il nous faut apporter une solution
rapide nous allons par ailleurs ouvrir
aux agents contractuels des voies
d'accès spécifique à l'emploi titulaire
alors là encore je veux être très clair
ce sera une mesure limitée dans le temps
c'est à dire pour les quatre prochaines
années et pour des personnes à compter
de la publication de la loi et pour des
personnes qui sont en situation de cdd
ou cdi depuis au moins quatre ans quatre
ans sur sur une perte de 6 années
consécutives
en clair qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que les personnes qui ont
acquis une expérience et pour lequel y
aura une volonté des collectivités ou de
l'état d'ouvrir un certain nombre de
postes et bien pourrez accéder par la
valorisation des acquis d'expérience à
un poste d'emploi titulaire donc ce sera
un examen spécifique on aura l'occasion
de revenir dans le détail mais là aussi
c'est une possibilité de valoriser les
acquis de l'expérience et d'ouvrir aussi
des perspectives professionnelles donc
aux agents qui sont directement
concernés
je vais vous dire parce que je sais les
interrogations qui ont eu un certain
nombre d'agents notamment ceux qui sont
dans l'éducation nationale ce qu'on
appelle le savez des 10 sur 12
par exemple des professeurs contractuels
du fonds comptent bauchet pour dix mois
enfin recruté pour 10 mois
ensuite on licencie en quelque sorte
pendant les deux mois puis on reprend et
j'ai eu là encore des témoignages des
mondes entre en fonction comme i la
fonction publique
je souhaite mettre un terme aussi à
cette situation et donc je vous
proposerai j'ai bien entendu les
attentes qui ont été exprimés je
souhaite qu'on y réponde et donc je vous
proposerai par voie d'amendement
d'étendre le bénéfice de cette
disposition donc de la titularisation à
tous ceux qui à l'instar des professeurs
contractuels comme je venais de le dire
sont recrutés par durée la recontre à
durée déterminée le 10 mois sur 12
on apportera une réponse je souhaite en
tout cas que cela fasse l'objet d'une
convergence si ce n'est je vais pas une
moue de consensus mais moins de
convergence ça permettra en tout cas de
régler la situation des agents
aujourd'hui en situation de précarité
est le gouvernement prendra ses
responsabilités et déposera un
amendement devant le sénat la grande
nouveauté de ce texte c'est que c'est
pas simplement d'un mot parfois
malheureuses qu'on appelle le stock des
personnes qui sont concernées
la grande nouveauté du texte c'est de
permettre de régler aussi dans la durée
cette question des cdd et donc il y aura
un caractère automatique pour les
emplois donc je dis bien je le précise
sur des emplois permanents
transformation automatique en cdi au
bout de six années
donc comme je voulais 10 pour régler le
problème de la situation aujourd'hui des
personnes qui sont dans ce cas
donc on réglera ce sera la nouveauté de
manière durable
si vous suivez la proposition du
gouvernement et des syndicats de manière
durable cette question des emplois
précaires
enfin je souhaite que nous puissions
aborder les conditions de recours à des
agents contractuels je sais que là aussi
il y avait des situations très diverses
les procédures de recrutement ce que je
vous propose seront mieux formaliser la
durée des maximales des contrats sera
amélioré aussi dans un certain cas pour
tenir compte des réalités des
collectivités territoriales mesdames les
sénateurs naturellement et elle n'oublie
pas pour être président par ailleurs
d'un conseil général en côte d'or que
évidemment il faut aussi permettre des
situations de remplacement de stabilité
ou en tout cas des vacances de postes
qui seraient limitées dans le temps
donc nous allons organiser tout ça de
façon un peu plus formalisé avec une
durée maximum de contrats pour besoin
temporaire qui sera harmonisée et
assouplit aussi pour certains aspects
enfin le gouvernement entend par voie
réglementaire améliorer également les
droits et la situation de l'ensemble des
agents contractuels
ceux ci auront désormais accès aux
dispositifs de formation professionnelle
nous souhaitons aussi que ceux qui sont
recrutés sur des besoins permanents
puissent bénéficier d'un entretien
professionnel annuel savait qu'on a
modernisé notre gestion de la fonction
publique avec ce système de notation de
0,25 etc
on lui a substitué un entretien
professionnel annuel je pense que c'est
une maman management bon management de
la ressource humaine de la fonction
publique
donc ils pourront bénéficier d'un
entretien professionnel annuel
et puis conformément à l'esprit de la
loi du 5 juillet 2010
portant rénovation du dialogue social
dans la fonction publique les agents
contractuels bénéficieront aussi d'une
garantie de représentation au sein de
nos différentes instances de
concertation
d'ailleurs je veux le dire aussi devant
vous cette garantie est apportée lors
des élections professionnelles vous
savez que pour la première fois le 20
octobre dernier
fonction publique d'état et fonction
publique hospitalière ont été à voter
ensemble pour désigner à participer pour
désigner leurs représentants
et c'est la première fois que les agents
non titulaires ont pu participer à ce
grand rendez-vous de démocratie sociale
de yarakh du taux de participation qui
montre bien l'application du seuil des
agents et nous ayons besoin
d'organisation syndicale représentative
pour assurer un dialogue social de
qualité entre les employeurs et elles
représentant des des fonctionnaires j'ai
pris bonne note aussi de l'avancée que
constitue la proposition de monsieur
vial et portelli adopté d'ailleurs
madame de reporter je crois en
commission qui vise à créer des
commissions consultatives paritaires
pour traiter spécifiquement les
situations individuelles des
contractuels je dois dire que ça
corresponde volonté partagée d'ailleurs
aussi pour mon est entretenu et les
syndicats
quoi qu'il souhaite pas non plus que les
situations personnelles d'agents
contractuels soient examinées en 6 ap
donc je crois que c'est là une avancée
sur lequel nous pourrons nous retrouver
en tout cas le gouvernement
je voulais 10 sera attentif aux
propositions du parlement et notamment
des sénateurs et des sénatrices et de
vos propositions madame la rapporteure
donc je vous dis d'ores et déjà que
c'est une proposition qu'on pourra
retenir au moins du débat en tout cas
c'est une avancée telles sont les
grandes lignes de l'accord conformément
aux engagements que le gouvernement a
pris en dira en direction des
organisations signataires
je souhaite que nos débats ne conduisent
pas dénaturer le contenu de cet accord
c'est un souci que douteuses ont à voir
en partage madame le rapporteur mais je
sais que c'est le cas puisque je m'en
suis longuement entretenu avec vous
comme avec l'ensemble des groupes de ce
que j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
jean vient à présent aux autres
questions traitées par ce projet de loi
d'abord la question de la lutte contre
les discriminations ma conviction
mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs c'est que la fonction
publique se doit d'être exemplaire et
d'être à l'image de la population
qu'elle sert elle doit être
quand j'ai dix exemplaires exemplaires
dans la lutte contre les discriminations
cela vaut pour les discriminations liées
à l'origine sociale ou géographique
d'ailleurs par parenthèse je me réjouis
du succès des classes préparatoires
intégrées je suis allé les rencontrer
les témoignages que j'ai recueillis de
ces personnes issus parfois de la
diversité où il suit de milieux modestes
et qui ont accédé à ccc classes
préparatoires montre bien que mon raison
de les encourager
ça vaut pour l'insertion aussi des
personnes en situation de handicap nous
avons progressé nous devons continuer de
progresser
d'ailleurs le premier s'est exprimé
récemment sur ce sujet vous savez cela
vaut aussi pour l'égalité
professionnelle femmes hommes
c'est-à-dire l'égal accès à des postes
de responsabilité des femmes et des
hommes
en l'état je je vous fais une confidence
qui n'en est plus une
oui vous avez raison on doit progresser
mais je vais revenir en l'état le projet
de loi tel qui vous est présentée
complète la loi du 13 juillet 1983 il
prévoir une communication futur conseil
commun de la fonction publique que
j'installerai d'ailleurs dans les tout
prochains jours
donc ils prévoient une communication de
rapports faisant état à la fois des
actions menées en faveur de ligne et du
thé professionnelle et de l'insertion
des personnes en situation de handicap
ce sera un rapport qui sera public rendu
public et qui permettra de mesurer
l'évolution de la situation
donc c'est une avancée incontestable que
chaque année en tout cas ce sujet soit
évoqué au sein du conseil commun de la
fonction publique une négociation
madame la sénatrice une négociation est
actuellement en cours avec les
organisations syndicales sur cette
question de l'égalité professionnelle
femmes hommes devraient m'amener à
présenter des amendements
si nous avons avancé suffisamment
rapidement devant l'assemblée nationale
mais je veux prendre un engagement
devant vous mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs c'est que je ne déposerai
aucun amendement qui ne sera
préalablement discuté aussi avec vous
madame le rapporteur contenu
calendrier tout ce que nous pouvons
faire avancer de manière convergente et
pour améliorer la situation de l'égalité
femmes-hommes nous le serons mais pour
respecter le sénat je prends
l'engagement devant vous que nous le
ferons en harmonie avec madame le
rapporteur je vais également évoqué une
question qui a trait à la mobilité et
les modifications que ce projet apporte
à la loi du 3 août 2009
donc qui était une loi vous en souvenez
relative à la mobilité et aux parcours
professionnels action ou d'un fonction
publique c'est là un sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur car il apporte
à mes yeux que nous donnions à chaque
agent de la fonction publique la
possibilité de construire aussi son
parcours professionnel de le construire
sur la base de ses compétences de ses
goûts de son de son implication et
qu'ils puissent bénéficier d'une 20
carrière conforme à ses attentes et à
celles aussi naturellement de l'exercice
d'un métier qui n'est pas un métier
comme un autre et celui d'être au
service du public
une mission de service public les
dispositions introduites dans sex
permettront de faciliter les mobilités
d'abord au sein de chaque fonction de
chaque fonction publique et on peut on
doit progresser dans cette matière mais
aussi entre les fonctions publiques
d'ailleurs je compte beaucoup sur les
travaux du conseil commun aussi pour
pour évoquer ces sujets passerelles
entre les différentes fonctions
publiques
enfin que ne soit pas considérée
l'entrée dans la fonction publique comme
une sorte de tunnel dans lequel on
serait engagé son destin est dépendante
finalement que des points qu'on acquiert
au fur et à mesure des évolutions de sa
carrière sa durée je pense qu'il faut
moderniser aussi ce management de nos
fonctions publiques
alors il ya un gros chapitre qui a
d'ailleurs j'ai noté qu'il y avait une
vraie station madame heures madame la
rapporteur sur les juridictions
administratives et financières a c'est
carrément l'inflation normative en tout
cas liste a dit puisque j'ai noté qu' on
est passé de six articles à 15 et que
vous l'avez considérablement enrichie au
point qu' il y aura encore huit nouveaux
amendements qui ont été déposés bon très
franchement je ne souhaite pas que ce
sujet par l'importance qu'il tente à
prendre dans ce projet de loi nous fasse
perdre de vue la finalité de ce projet
est d'abord de lutter contre la
précarité
bien évidemment les juridictions doivent
évoluer
non des dispositions qui sont dans le
texte on s'en doute leur utilité
d'ailleurs si vous les avez retenu c'est
que est assurément une utilité mais dans
le même temps il faut pas qu'on ait de
trompions d'objectifs
c'est à dire qu'il nous faut faire
aboutir ce qui peut être consensuelle
entre nous et remettre à d'autres
occasions ce qui l'est moins
donc c'est sur cette base que nous
pourrons examiner les propositions de la
commission
je veux enfin pour terminer à bord des
trois sujets un sujet qui a fait
vraiment débat avec le président de la
commission des lois du sénat avec
certains d'entre vous aussi avec vous
madame la rapporteure c'est la question
de la nouvelle procédure d'affectation
de les élèves de l'école nationale
d'administration que je souhaite voir
évoluer
j'ai observé qu'il y avait des positions
comment dirais-je trancher entre les
partisans du placement la sortie des nas
qui était partisan d'une évolution afin
que ce soit pas les élèves qui
choisissent simplement leur destin dans
les grands corps et qu'il y ait un
rapprochement entre les employeurs et
des aspirations des employeurs les
élèves de la sortie de l'ena en tout cas
bon j'ai réuni je veux en informer le
sénat hier soir une commission pour
rapprocher les points de vue d'ailleurs
le président sûr il ya participé à ces
pleins d'amour la miss manosque a
également vous y avaient participé
je ne me désespère pas de parvenir
sinon elle consensus en tout cas du
rapprochement de points de vue et nous
avons encore deux réunions prévues sur
ce sujet et bien si j'espère que nous
arriverons à avancer avant le début de
l'examen du texte à l'assemblée
nationale en tout cas vous avez compris
que je tiens à ce que les choses
évoluent parce que c'est un sujet sur
lequel nous ont fait un constat c'est
qu'elles ne peuvent pas rester en l'état
sur les sorties
donc à partir du moment ne peuvent pas
rester en l'état il nous appartient de
trouver des voies d'amélioration
deuxième sujet c'est celui des droits et
des moyens syndicaux
j'ai souhaité qu'on avance sur cette
question qui a fait l'objet de débats de
commission denquête vous l'avez vu j'ai
souhaité que cette question soit abordée
dès mon arrivée en fonction et donc avec
les organisations syndicales dans
beaucoup travaillé sur
la sécurisation des droits et des moyens
et en même temps un sujet sur lequel
étaient très attachés c'est que dès lors
qu'il s'agit de moyens publics
nous devons avoir une transparence
totale sur les conditions de
réutilisation s'agit pas de faire de
l'inquisition de rechercher à connaître
les utilisations mais la transparence
est une des règles dans le
fonctionnement public
nous sommes parvenus un relevé de
conclusions là encore c'est un dialogue
nourri avec des organisations syndicales
sensible aussi comme sujet ne nous le
cachons pas un
nous sommes parvenus à un relevé de
conclusions le 29 septembre dernier
madame le rapporteur ce principe d'abord
le râble relevé de conclusion c'est que
saint principe à périmètre constant
moyens qu'on sent évidemment il faut
tenir compte de le nombre des instances
de concertation sur va avoir un dialogue
syndical nourrit il faut aussi permettre
que ce dialogue puisse avoir lieu dans
les différentes instances de
concertation qui étaient ouvertes y
compris sur les conditions de travail
les fameuses cfct donc à périmètre
premier principe km est constant moyens
constants deuxième principe c'est la
transparence sur la mise à disposition
et l'utilisation de ces moyens
ce sera désormais le cas des moyens dont
je rappelle que les règles d'attribution
n'avait pas été revu depuis 30 ans donc
c'est une avancée là aussi pour lequel
je tiens à saluer l'esprit de
responsabilité des syndicats qu'avait
d'ailleurs pour ne rien vous cacher des
positions extrêmement divergentes sur
les conditions de la répartition des
moyens mis à leur disposition à l'issue
d'élections professionnelles mais j'ai
souhaité qu'on en fixe le principe avant
même les élections professionnelles
naturellement cette réforme je tenais
particulièrement elle sera appliquée
vous savez par voie réglementaire pour
ce qui concerne la fonction publique
d'état
donc sur les droits des moyens elle le
sera par voie réglementaire dans la
fonction publique hospitalière mais
nécessite une intervention de
législatives que vous est proposé
aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne la
fonction publique territoriale il encore
un accord je souhaiterais qu'on puisse
s'y convergeaient sur le fait que
l'accord ont piste le respecté puisqu'il
a fait l'objet de nombreuses heures de
négociations donc c'est une étape très
importante de la rénovation du dialogue
social qui est engagée en application
des accords de bercy de juin 2008 est de
la loi du 5 juillet 2010 enfin troisième
sujet ce sera le dernier en lien avec
mon collègue fille richerdt je vous
présenterai plusieurs dispositions
concernant la réforme de l'encadrement
supérieur de la fonction publique
territoriale des dispositions qui là
encore son très attendu je suis allé à
brest
récemment un congrès notamment d
encadrement supérieur et j'ai bien vu
qu'il y avait là une forte attente
d'ailleurs j'observe ça fait deux ans
que le conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique territoriale avait formulé sous
la responsabilité de son président son
nouveau président philippe laurent des
propositions de revalorisation de
l'encadrement supérieur dans un rapport
qui était intitulé quels cadres
dirigeants pour relever les défis de la
république décentralisée
donc sur ce sur ce dossier quel objectif
il est double assurer une transposition
harmonieuse de la réforme dans
l'encadrement supérieur de la fonction
publique territoriale telle qu'elle
était mise en oeuvre dans la fonction
publique de l'état
deuxième objectif c'est de garantir la
cohérence d'ensemble des carrières des
emplois dans la fonction publique
territoriale
une modernisation similaire est
également en cours pour la pour la
fonction publique hospitalière
elle interviendra là par voie
réglementaire l'encore en conclusion je
voudrais mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs pour dire que le texte que
nous examinons aujourd'hui c'est un
texte de responsabilité
c'est un texte de justice sociale s'agit
pour l'état et l'ensemble des
collectivités publiques de france d'
assumer un devoir d'exemplarité qui doit
inspirer tous les employeurs publics et
je tiens vraiment à saluer le caractère
de convergence en tout cas que vous avez
porté avec la commission des lois lors
de l'examen de ce texte
je souhaite vraiment je vous le dis que
cet état d'esprit se poursuivent en
séance en tout cas madame la rapporteure
et je le dis à l'ensemble des sénateurs
j'y suis prêt pour ce qui me concerne le
nom du gouvernement
ah ça que nous puissions adopter ce
projet de loi car je le redis ce texte
est attendue par l'ensemble de ceux qui
fonctionnaires ou non ont fait le choix
de servir nos compatriotes
le choix de servir l'intérêt général au
sein du service public
ils l'attendent il est de notre devoir
aujourd'hui d'y répondre
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame catherine tasca
rapporteur de la commission des lois
monsieur madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre
madame mes chers collègues le
législateur et est appelée à valider les
termes d'un accord négocié entre le
gouvernement et les organisations
syndicales
le présent projet de loi déposée sur le
bureau du sénat le 7 septembre 2011 est
d'abord et principalement consacrée à
cet exercice
transposée dans la loi les dispositions
du protocole signé le 31 mars 2011 pour
sécuriser les parcours professionnels
des agents contractuels dans les trois
versants de la fonction publique
ce texte monsieur le ministre apparaît
comme une éclaircie dans un contexte
très sombre de dénigrement systématique
des fonctionnaires et de réduction
drastique des effectifs dans le cadre de
la rgpp
il ne serait donc occulter les
difficultés croissantes du
fonctionnement des services publics
par suite des suppressions de postes ce
texte apporte des réponses concrètes à
des situations d'injustice et de
précarité son efficacité dépendra de la
réalité de sa mise en oeuvre et du
nombre de postes ouverts à la
titularisation
votre commission des lois a abordé avec
pragmatisme le présent projet de loi qui
se présente comme un texte
essentiellement technique par un
mouvement naturel s'y est greffé un
ensemble de dispositions répondant à des
difficultés d'importance inégale
retouches aux lois de 2009 et 2010 sur
la mobilité et le dialogue social
élargissement du vivier de recrutement
des juridictions administratives et
financières dont les projets de réforme
attendue depuis plusieurs années n'ont à
ce jour pas abouti
ce projet de loi est le dernier train de
la présente législature
il constitue l'ultime opportunité de
modifier ou de compléter les statuts
pour en conforter la cohérence et la
bonne marche des
sitution public c'est à cette aune que
suivant son rapporteur
la commission des lois a examiné le
projet soumis à son examen par réalisme
elle a retenu les divers volets qu'il
contient elle regrette cependant leur
hétérogénéité qui n'est pas de bonne
pratique législative
c'est pourquoi la commission a décidé de
s'en tenir au périmètre ainsi fixé afin
de maintenir à l'ensemble une certaine
cohérence et de ne pas anticiper des
réformes qui mérite d'être débattue dans
le cadre d'un débat spécifique
j'aborderai tout d'abord le coeur du
texte constitué par ce nouveau plan de
résorption de la précarité qui fragilise
de nombreux agents non titulaires
malgré les efforts passés et la
titularisation de dizaines de milliers
d'entre eux qui ne furent que des
améliorations fugitive la situation
antérieure est réapparu le recours
commode aux non titulaires ne se tarit
pas variable d'ajustement d'effectifs
tendu beaucoup trop sont maintenus dans
la précarité alors même qu'ils
contribuent à assurer durablement un
fonctionnement normal du service public
cette fois cependant votre rapporteur
note que ce 15e plan s'accompagne d'une
sécurisation pour les dix ont recalé par
la voie du cb par la voix de la cedh et
lisa sion et de plusieurs mesures qui
devraient principalement renforcer
l'accès au cdi
votée en 2005 par le législateur
approuvant dans son ensemble l'esprit du
double volet consacré aux contractuels
plan de titularisation et réforme du
régime juridique des contrats
la commission des lois tout en y
apportant des corrections techniques en
à renforcer les garanties sur plusieurs
points le dispositif spécifique de
titularisation arrêté au terme de la
concertation conduite par le
gouvernement repose sur un équilibre
acceptée par les partenaires sociaux
dans leur plus grande majorité
le fait est assez rare pour être
souligné
et soutenu votre commission n'entend pas
altéré cet équilibre le législateur qui
en 2010 a rénové le cadre légal du
dialogue social est aujourd'hui appelé
pour la première fois depuis cette
réforme à donner force de loi aux
conclusion fructueuse d'un accord en
conséquence en dehors de diverses
rectifications destinés a précisé le
texte
assurer sa cohérence dans
l'ordonnancement juridique et sa
lisibilité
la commission des lois essentiellement
adopté quatre modifications
par cohérence et elle a tout d'abord
intégré dans le calcul de l'ancienneté
requise
les services accomplis pour assurer le
remplacement de fonctionnaires
momentanément absents ou autorisés à
exercer leur fonction à temps partiel et
d'autre part pour pourvoir à une vacance
temporaire d'emploi
elle a fondé le droit d'accès à l'emploi
titulaire sur la réalité des services
effectués par le candidat
à cette fin elle a distingué le cdi pour
lequel la titularisation s'effectuerait
dans un corps ou cadres dont les
fonctions sont de même niveau que celles
occupées au 31 mars 2011
l'agent en cdd pour sa part accéderez à
la catégorie dans laquelle il a exercé
le plus longtemps s'il a quatre ans
d'ancienneté au delà de quatre ans à la
catégorie la plus élevée
quel que soit le temps qu'il y à passer
pour tenir compte de la diversité des
employeurs territoriaux la commission
leur a ouvert la faculté de confier
l'examen de la recevabilité de la
candidature pour le cadre d'emploi
ouvert par le recrutement auquel il se
présente à la commission d'évaluation
professionnelle mise en place pour
conduire les élections professionnelles
le choix ainsi offert à l'autorité
territoriale devrait faciliter la mise
en oeuvre du dispositif de
titularisation notamment dans les
petites collectivités
enfin la commission a étendu le bénéfice
du dispositif aux contractuels des
administrations parisiennes
ainsi qu'aux personnels des
établissements qui seraient exclues du
bénéfice des dérogations à l'emploi
titulaire
la commission a aussi sécurisé pour
l'avenir la situation de ces agents
ainsi que de ceux des institutions sous
le même régime dérogatoire qui
réintégrait au gré des aléas de
l'architecturé administrative et
institutionnelle le droit commun de
l'emploi statutaire les clarifications
apportées au régime des contrats pour
prévenir les effets pervers des
modalités actuelles du renouvellement
des contrats et de leur transformation
en cdi mérite d'être approuvée dans
leurs principes en resserrant leurs
conditions d'emploi le texte aujourd'hui
présenté au parlement devrait écarter à
l'avenir les abus les plus criants les
rapprochement opéré entre les trois
versants de la fonction publique ainsi
que la réaffirmation du principe
essentiel de l'emploi titulaire
permettront de conforter le statut alors
que la place du cdi est élargie dans le
même temps certes la sévérisation et le
moyen de lutter contre la précarité mais
elle ne doit pas devenir une voie
parallèle de recrutement dans les
services publics
votre rapporteur demeure cependant
prudent sur les résultats escomptés
seule la pratique permettra d'en mesurer
les effets il n'en reste pas moins que
les modifications proposées devraient
limiter les détournements du mécanisme
est davantage sécuriser la situation des
personnels concernés
c'est pourquoi son initiative la
commission des lois n'a apporté à ce
second volet traduction fidèle de la kz2
du protocole du 31 mars 2011 que des
amendements destinés à préciser
assouplir clarifier et compléter les
mesures proposées elle a notamment
portée de trois à quatre mois la durée d
interruption entre deux contre un qui
autorise la prise en compte des services
discontinus dans le calcul de la durée
de la conduite
long de 6 ans pour l'accès au cdi cet
élargissement devrait notamment
sécuriser la situation de nombreux
contractuels de l'éducation nationale le
titre iii du projet de loi comporte des
dispositions destinées principalement à
renforcer la mobilité des fonctionnaires
dans l'esprit qui a présidé au vote de
la loi du 3 août 2009
votre commission est favorable à ces
assouplissements qui renforceront les
possibilités pour les fonctionnaires de
conduire des parcours professionnels
diversifier sous réserve de plusieurs
harmonisation précision et
actualisations du texte proposé afin
d'en conforter la cohérence juridique la
commission a notamment voulu clarifier
la faculté nouvelle d'une mise à
disposition à l'étranger auprès d'
entités fédérées pour des missions
confiées en france à l'état elle a par
ailleurs sur proposition du gouvernement
ajustez ponctuellement les loi
statutaire pour tenir compte de la
suppression d'une part du paritarisme au
conseil supérieur de la fonction
publique de l'état
en adoptant en adaptant sa composition
lorsqu'ils siègent en tant qu'organe
supérieur de recours là le paritarisme
est évidemment nécessaire de la
disparition d'autres par des sièges
précipitèrent au conseil supérieur de la
fonction publique territoriale
en ce qui concerne la composition des
conseils régionaux d'orientation placé
auprès du délégué régional du centre
national de la fonction publique
territoriale
par ailleurs la commission des lois a
retenu l'institution de commissions
consultatives paritaires pour les
contractuels des collectivités
territoriales proposé par notre collègue
hugues portelli
la commission a complété le projet de
loi en adoptant un ensemble de mesures
d'harmonisation et d'ajustements
ponctuels proposée par le gouvernement
elle a tiré les conséquences de la
réforme des retraites de 2010 en
prévoyant un dispositif transitoire pour
les fonctionnaires territoriaux en congé
spécial et en alignant
l'âge d'ouverture des droits à retraite
des agents publics ayant la qualité de
travailleur handicapé sur celui du
régime général d'assurance vieillesse en
abaissant de trois à un mois la durée du
sursis de l'exclusion temporaire des
fonctions dans la fonction publique
territoriale sur celles des deux autres
versants et en fixant au 16 juin 2011
date d'entrée en vigueur du décret
classant en catégorie b les personnels
du corps des permanenciers auxiliaires
de régulation médicale
la date d'effet de leur intégration en
prolongeant de trois ans jusqu'au 31
décembre 2016
la période durant laquelle les
fonctionnaires de la poste peuvent
demander leur intégration dans un décor
ou cadre d'emplois des trois fonctions
publiques d'état territoriale et
hospitalière
la commission des lois a complété le
volet consacré aux juridictions
administratives et financières avec la
volonté de renforcer leurs moyens de
travail et de faciliter ainsi l'exercice
de leurs missions
il s'agit principalement d'élargir leur
vivier de recrutement notamment pour
pallier le tarissement progressif des
promesses des promotions de l'école
nationale d'administration décidé par le
gouvernement
l'ensemble de ces dispositions celle
proposée initialement par le projet de
loi comme les ajouts de la commission
parfois bien au-delà des clivages
partisans reprennent pour partie les
dispositions d'une part d'un
avant-projet de loi de 2008 consacrée
aux juridictions administratives mais
jamais déposé devant le parlement
et d'autre part du projet de réforme des
juridictions financières déposé en
octobre 2009 à l'assemblée nationale
mais dont l'examen n'a pas dépassé le
stade de la commission
je me réjouis que la commission des lois
du sénat en adoptant à l'unanimité le
texte modifié et suivi la position de
son rapporteur en approuvant l'élargisse
de l'accès au conseil d'état des
conseillers les tribunaux administratifs
et des cours administratives d'appel par
la voix du tour extérieur ou encore par
l'affectation de magistrats dt ha et des
cours administratives d'appel au conseil
d'état auprès de la mission d'inspection
des juridictions administratives
de plus il me semble que la
pérennisation du concours dit
complémentaire de recrutement de membres
des tribunaux administratifs et cours
administratives d'appel provisoire mes
chers collègues depuis 1977 et est
devenu indispensable
la proposition du gouvernement de
détacher dans le corps des magistrats de
chambre régionale des comptes
des militaires et des professeurs
titulaires des universités et
l'alignement de la durée des
incompatibilités applicables aux
magistrats déco régionale des comptes
sur celles des autres fonctionnaires
soit trois ans semble tout à fait
justifié notre commission est toutefois
allé plus loin
elle a rendu obligatoire la nomination
au conseil d'état chaque année d'un
second maître des requêtes choisi parmi
les membres des tribunaux administratifs
et cours administratives d'appel
elle a instauré la qualité de maître des
requêtes en service extraordinaire elle
a pérennisé le recrutement
complémentaire de conseillers des
chambres régionales des comptes
elle a facilité la mobilité des
présidents de tribunaux administratifs
échos administrative d'appel en limitant
à sept le nombre d'années qu'ils peuvent
passer à la tête d'une même juridiction
elle a sur proposition avisés de notre
collègue michel delebarre consacré le
statut de magistrat administratif des
membres des tribunaux administratifs et
des cours administratives d'appel elle à
diversifier le vivier des recrutements
effectués par la voix du tour extérieur
au grade de conseiller référendaire à la
cour des comptes elle a assorti de
garanties supplémentaires les
détachements dans le corps des chambres
le décompte bref le texte de la
commission des lois s'efforce
d'organiser plus efficacement encore les
moyens humains dont disposent les
juridictions administratives et
financières
je regrette cependant qu'il n'ait pas
été possible d'examiner ces dispositions
dans le cadre de textes spécifiquement
consacré à ces juridictions
votre rapporteur souhaite comme l'a fait
lui-même le ministre mais sans nullement
pour autant donner quitus au
gouvernement de sa politique en matière
d'emploi dans la fonction publique que
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
très attendu face l'objet d'un examen
serein compte tenu de l'ensemble de ces
observations je vous invite
mes chers collègues à concrétiser
l'accord du 31 mars 2011
je veux répéter ici que c'est un
événement dans l'histoire du dialogue
social dans la fonction publique dans
notre pays est un événement aussi pour
le parlement d'avoir à s'appuyer et à
traduire dans la loi un accord qui a été
obtenu avec une telle participation des
organisations syndicales et j'ai été
inspiré tout au long de l'examen de ce
texte par la conviction que ces
organisations syndicales attendaient de
la représentation nationale qu'elle
donne réalité qu'elle donne vie dans la
loi aux termes de cet accord
votre rapporteur forme donc le voeu que
l'ensemble de ces dispositions
améliorent l'environnement statutaires
et les conditions d'emploi de ces
milliers d'agents publics qui dans les
administrations de l'état dans les
collectivités locales les hôpitaux
assure chaque jour le bon fonctionnement
de nos services publics
pour l'heure la commission des loi
soumet à la délibération du sénat le
texte qu'elle a établies je vous
remercie
merci merci madame le rapporteur dans la
suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame corinne bouchoux
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
pédagogie c'est l'art de la répétition
et nous allons répéter ici même
quelques-uns des motifs de satisfaction
souligné par la rapporteure de la
commission des lois dont nous voudrions
ici souligner le travail et le sens du
consensus
pour autant nous voudrions signaler
également les limites de ce texte est un
certain nombre de points que nous
voudrions ne pas voir perdre de vue
premier point évidemment ce texte vient
sceller un dialogue social qui est le
bienvenu qui est peut-être parfois trop
rare dans ce pays
évidemment on peut aussi voir un effet
calendrier des initiatives qui vont
apparaître d'ici trois mois
alors oui ce texte va réduire la
précarité et il faut le dire
l'état n'était pas toujours un bon
employeur l'état qui essaye d'être
exemplaire à plus souvent donner un
mauvais exemple avec plusieurs centaines
de milliers de personnes en emploi de
précarité avec du temps partiel subi
avec des conditions de travail dégradées
avec une mobilité imposée avec
l'impossibilité de savoir si le contrat
sera ou non renouvelé la possibilité de
savoir notamment pour ces enseignants
s'ils retrouveront en septembre ou non
un emploi
au-delà des chiffres qui ont été donnés
tout à l'heure et je voudrais insister
sur ce point il y à cette réalité si
l'on considère qu'il ya huit cent mille
personnes touchées par un emploi
précaire dans la fonction publique il y
a quatre millions de personnes qui
gravitent autour de ces salariés qui
connaissent la précarité et
contrairement ce que l'on peut penser la
précarité ce n'est pas seulement dans
l'industrie ce n'est pas seulement dans
les services
c'est aussi au service de l'état et des
collectivités territoriales
alors nous pouvons effectivement ici que
saluer les avancées avec d'une part la
résorption de cet immense poche de
précarité qui était devenue extrêmement
importantes au fil des ans
et d'autre part nous ne pouvons que
louer le souci qu'il ya de mieux définir
le contrat
le cdi dans la fonction publique afin
d'avoir une loi plus visés
bhl plus sur des conditions de durée de
renouvellement plus claire des contrats
harmoniser et aussi effectivement la
question cruciale du passage de cdd au
cdi
sur tous ces points et les syndicats
comme l'a dit la rapporteure nous l'ont
fait savoir
il souhaite que la représentation
nationale donne acte des accords qui ont
été trouvés nous ne pouvons les suivre
et que les suivre sur ces points et les
entendre pour autant il nous semble
important de ne pas remettre en cause le
statut de la fonction publique
si malmenée ces dernières années par des
mesures ultra libérale qui se masque
derrière des vocables de management de
nouvelle gestion des ressources humaines
ou malheureusement la réalité n'est pas
à la hauteur du discours qui est tenu
nous aimerions ici redire en tant
qu'écologiste notre attachement au
maintien du statut de la fonction
publique à ce que sont les
fonctionnaires même si nous sommes très
satisfaits qu'aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de personnes puissent quitter la
précarité faut avoir une situation plus
digne plus stables au service de l'état
ou des collectivités territoriales pour
l'avenir et ce doit être dit nous ne
sommes pas favorables à la casse
organisée systématiquement actuellement
de la fonction publique avec une
politique relativement aveugle de la
rgpp qui mécaniquement supprime un
emploi sur deux pour aller ensuite
recruter contrairement aux textes des
personnes précaires que l'on va malmener
et qui bouchent les trous du service
public le service public n'est plus
capable de rendre lui même et donc nous
pensons que l'actuel texte que nous
discutons aujourd'hui ne doit pas
masquer la question très importante du
statut de la fonction publique et du
fonctionnement des services publics dans
notre pays
pour le dire autrement la posture
dogmatique sur la rgpp nous semble
devoir être revu et à cet égard le texte
que nous discutons nous semble
extrêmement important
les écologistes appellent à stopper
l'hémorragie notamment dans l'éducation
nationale
nous retournons dans nos
circonscriptions et entendons parler des
dizaines et des dizaines
d'emplois supprimés je pense qu'il faut
aussi entendre cela nous supprimons des
emplois et ensuite nous devons un pôle
emploi faire recruter des enseignants
précaires
monsieur le ministre il y a quelque
chose qui ne va pas dans cette logique
là il faut un autre une autre façon de
fonctionner c'est vrai en général et
notamment dans l'éducation nationale
pour le dire autrement nous ne sommes
pas favorables à démantèlement du
service public tel qu'il se met en place
actuellement
et même si la loi qui est aujourd'hui
discutée présente de nombreux motifs de
satisfaction
nous pensons que ça ne doit pas être
l'arbre qui cache la forêt nous voulons
des services publics de qualité une
fonction publique de qualité et même si
nous nous réjouissons pour toutes ces
personnes aujourd'hui qu'ils vont sortir
de la précarité par une civilisation par
l'accès à la fonction publique par des
concours adapté en aucun cas en aucun
cas les mesures prises aujourd'hui ne
doivent faire oublier ce qui se passe
actuellement en france alors nous
aimerions également que une réflexion
beaucoup plus profonde souhaite apporter
concernant deux points d'une part
l'égalité hommes femmes dans la fonction
publique et cela a été dit par la
rapporteure
nous pensons qu'en dépit des avancées
notables qui sont actés aujourd'hui la
situation reste préoccupante
et là aussi l'état est loin d'être
exemplaire et les collectivités
territoriales peuvent aussi faire des
progrès donc en matière d'égalité hommes
femmes
on peut faire beaucoup mieux c'est
quelque chose de très important il
faudra y insister nous ne pouvons nous
satisfaire de ce texte pourquoi parce
que ce texte va permettre la
déprécarisation d'un certain nombre de
personnes mais vous le savez comme moi
lorsqu'un catégorie à devient cdi il
peut travailler à 100%
il a un emploi 100% lorsqu'une personne
a enchaîné plusieurs contrats à durée
déterminée et qu'on lui propose un cdi
est calé catégorie b ou c elle va dans
un certain nombre de ministères et c'est
ainsi ne pouvoir travailler qu'à 70% du
temps cela veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que les plus précaires son public deux
fois et sont obligés de trouver un autre
emploi en complément pour vivre
dignement au service de l'état je pense
que c'est une question à laquelle il
faudra s'atteler aussi qui est très
importante
alors deuxième point donc l'égalité
homme-femme nous on pense qu'on peut
mieux faire et que ce texte ne répond qu
imparfaitement une grave question de
société on reste très très mauvais
deuxième point alors la commission des
lois sous
houlette d'un certain nombre de
collègues a essayé d'apporter des
améliorations très modeste parce qu'on
peut encore faire beaucoup mieux
c'est toute la question de l'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap
donc nous sommes dans un système
complètement ubuesque où parfois nous
avons des normes à appliquer que nous ne
pouvons pas appliquer un collègue ce
matin cité avec beaucoup de pertinence
les exemples de personnels de sécurité
ou de pompiers qui doivent avoir un
certain nombre de personnes en situation
de handicap pour être conforme aux
normes et quand vous n'avez pas huit sur
dix à vos deux yeux et que vous n'êtes
pas en parfaite santé et c'est normal
vous ne pouvez pas être pompier donc
tant que nous ne serons résoudre et
c'est ici aussi que cela peut se faire
des injonctions complètement
contradictoire dans des domaines où 2
nous devons favoriser l'accès à l'emploi
stable des personnes en situation de
handicap
nous n'avancerons pas et donc nous
pensons que ce texte même s'il est
intéressant ne va pas assez loin il faut
faire beaucoup plus il faut faire
beaucoup mieux
donc concernant les femmes et concernant
les personnes en situation de handicap
ce texte nous semble trop modeste et
pour le dire autrement non satisfaisants
alors dernier point et c'est un sujet
auquel nous tenons nous allons prendre
acte nous souhaitons aussi d'un accord
très important qui va déprécariser un
certain nombre de personnes nous pensons
qu'il est aussi très important de ne pas
négliger l'effort de formation pour ces
personnes ces personnes sont pour
certaines en situation de traumatismes
elles ont enchaîné les contrats ils ont
été malmenées elles ont vécu des
situations stressantes et angoissante et
nous pensons qu'une formation de qualité
digne de ce nom pour ses personnels est
une priorité absolue est peut-être le
texte en l'état ne montre pas assez
cette et forme de formation qui nous
semble très important de mettre en place
deuxième souhait alors c'est un petit
peu une autre touche particulière mais
c'est très important vous savez que nous
souhaitons un autre fonctionnement de la
société nous faisons la promotion d'un
certain nombre d'autres valeurs et nous
aimerions aussi que en matière de
gestion des ressources humaines
si je peux le dire de façon on va dire
un petit peu images et nous ayons une
gestion plus écologique et plus saine
des personnels dans la fonction publique
et que nous ne traitions plus jamais les
personnes précaires comme nous venons de
le faire ces dernières années il faut
que cette loi soit la dernière loi de ce
type et à chaque fois qu'une loi est
votée on dit que c'est la dernière fois
il ça ne recommencera pas donc nous
lyon nous aimerions réellement que la
loi qui devra être votée ici prennent en
compte de façon extrêmement forte
les questions des plus précaires
notamment les catégories b et c la
question de l'emploi des femmes la
question des personnes en situation de
handicap
la question de la formation tout au long
de la vie et s'attelle aussi de façon
peut-être plus ambitieuse à la question
de la promotion dans la fonction
publique si vous regardez les derniers
rapports qui ont été publiés les hommes
profitent beaucoup plus que les femmes
des formations professionnelles les
hommes profitent beaucoup plus des
situations de formation continue et
malheureusement je dirais que c'est pas
mieux dans la fonction publique
et si vous regardez les dernières
statistiques la fonction publique tant à
faire moins bien que certaines grandes
entreprises privées donc ce serait bien
que à la faveur de ce texte on prenne la
mesure des efforts considérables que
doivent faire l'employeur que doivent
faire doivent eux faire les employeurs
publics avec leur personnel et pour que
nous soyons je dirais aussi vertueux
avec nos propres personnels que ce que
nous appelons de nos voeux dans les
entreprises privées et dans les
entreprises en général
vous l'aurez compris chers collègues
ce texte présente selon nous et les
syndicats ont beaucoup insisté sur ce
point une étape nécessaire dans la
reconsidération du travail précaire dans
la fonction publique nous ne pouvons que
prendre acte des avancées qui ont été
fait regretté certaines limites nous
l'avons fait lors de cette intervention
nous aimerions pour autant vous rappeler
que nous sommes extrêmement attachés à
une fonction publique de qualité ce qui
veut dire indépendamment du contexte que
nous mesurons bien avec la contrainte
budgétaire que nous savons nous sommes
réalistes mais nous pensons néanmoins
qu'il y ait un certain nombre de
secteurs sacrifiés qui ne pourront
l'être durablement
nous avons parlé de la formation nous
pouvons parler des hôpitaux nous pouvons
parler là certain nombre de secteurs où
nous ne pourrons plus nous contentons de
perdre contenter de personnels précaires
qui joue les bouche trous ça n'est pas
possible nous devons avoir une fonction
publique de qualité
si nous voulons des services publics de
qualité et il faut aussi y mettre le
prix y compris y compris en arbitrant
dans certaines priorités c'est
effectivement ici l'endroit pour en
parler voilà je vous remercie chers
collègues votre attention et nous
espérons vivement
que concernant tous ces sujets notamment
les personnes en situation de handicap
notamment les plus précaires tous ces
remarques seront prises en compte je
vous remercie
merci merci chers collègues
la parole est à mme le sujet jean paul
amoudry
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
madame le rapporteur monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers collègues
cela vient d'être rappelé le présent
projet de loi fait suite à une intense
concertation entre les partenaires
sociaux au printemps 2009 et à l'automne
2010 cette concertation a permis
l'établissement d'un diagnostic partagé
de tous sur la situation des agents
contractuels dans la fonction publique
et à démontrer l'existence d'un large
consensus sur l'opportunité d'une
réforme du cadre législatif et
réglementaire qui leur est applicable
cette réforme concerne l'ensemble des
agents contractuels fonction publique
d'état fonction publique territoriale et
fonction publique hospitalière une
négociation a ainsi été ouvertes entre
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux et
les représentants des employeurs
territoriaux et hospitaliers
elle s'est déroulée dans un cadre
juridique nouveau posée par la loi du 5
juillet 2010 portant rénovation du
dialogue social dans la fonction
publique le 31 mars 2011
cette négociation a abouti à la
signature d'un protocole d'accord
largement consensuel ce protocole a été
signé par six organisations syndicales
représentatives de la fonction publique
unsa cgt fo cfdt cgc cftc
le présent projet de loi vise dans ses
deux premiers titres à transposer les
stipulations de cet accord le processus
est exemplaire il faut le souligner
d'abord la concertation puis l'oeuvre de
législation il procède donc d'une
méthode logique et la démarche adoptée
en ce domaine par le gouvernement est la
bonne elle doit être saluée car les
étapes de négociation n'ont pas été
sacrifiées à l'urgence qu'il y avait à
portée d'une part une réponse immédiate
aux situations de précarité rencontrées
sur le terrain et d'autre part de
prévenir la reconstitution de situation
de précarité pour l'avenir en encadrant
mieux les cas de recours au contrat
telle était d'ailleurs les deux
principaux axes du protocole signé le 31
mars dernier
il est important de rappeler que les
agents non titulaires représente
aujourd'hui près de 6 16,8 pour cent des
effectifs de l'ensemble de la fonction
publique soit quelque 900 mille agents
en fm recours
aux contractuels n'a cessé de se
développer au cours de ces dernières
années pour les collectivités
territoriales
l'accroissement et la diversification de
leurs compétences consécutif à la
décentralisation ont entraîné un recours
croissant aux agents non titulaires de
nouveaux métiers doivent être exercées
par nos collectivités aussi bien au
niveau communal intercommunale et
départementales et des employeurs
territoriaux ont donc dû recruter dans
des domaines particuliers très
spécialisés domaine où il n'est pas aisé
voire impossible dans certains cas de
disposer de fonctionnaires ayant les
qualifications nécessaires comme le
relève en effet l'étude d'impact la
majorité des non titulaires sont
recrutés pour des besoins très
spécifiques
le titre premier du texte vise à
répondre aux situations de précarité
parfois rencontrées par certains agents
qui bénéficie d'une solide expérience
professionnelle auprès de leur employeur
et qui n'ont pu pour diverses raisons
accéder à l'emploi titulaire ni
bénéficier d'une transformation de leur
contrat en contrat à durée indéterminée
le projet de loi prévoit qu'un cdi sera
obligatoirement proposer aux
contractuels justifiant notamment d'une
ancienneté le service de six années
cette mesure est destinée aux agents qui
ne pourraient pas accéder à l'emploi
titulaire mais également à ceux qui ne
le souhaiterait pas la situation de ces
agences ainsi stabilisé par le bénéfice
de cette transformation
avec toutes les garanties qu'elle
offrira au quotidien aux titulaires de
ces nouveaux contrats ainsi ce texte
propose une approche responsable juste
qui prend en considération le fait que
depuis 2007 l'état demande des efforts
considérables et sans précédent aux
fonctionnaires notamment au travers de
la rgpp ou encore avec le gel du point
l'ensemble des dispositions de ce projet
permette de mettre un terme à quantité
de situations abusives vis-à-vis des
fonctionnaires
nous sommes convaincus que ce texte
fruit d'un dialogue fructueux avec les
partenaires sociaux atteindra son
objectif et permettra de réduire
efficacement la précarité qui fragilise
les agents contractuels comme la
pérennité du service public dans
certaines branches
je tiens enfin salué le travail
important qui a été menée en commission
des lois sur ce texte
ainsi que l'excellent rapport de notre
collègue catherine dacia elle a conduit
sur ce projet une réflexion de fond et
la plupart des aménagements introduit
lors de l'examen en commission étaient
les bienvenus cela étant je reste plus
réservé sur les dispositions relatives
au recrutement au sein des juridictions
administratives et financières
en effet la relation entre ce domaine
est l'objet initial du projet de loi
déposé par le gouvernement n'est
vraiment pas manifeste enfin je ne peux
manquer de regretter que malgré la non
ce contenu dans le titre du projet de
loi à savoir la lutte contre les
discriminations ce texte ne résout pas
les difficultés rencontrées par les
personnes en situation de handicap
je note néanmoins avec beaucoup de
satisfaction que notre commission des
lois s'est engagé à aborder de manière
volontariste et constructive cette très
importante question sous réserve de ces
quelques observations
une très large majorité du groupe de
l'union centriste et républicaine votre
en faveur de ce projet de loi
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur christian
favier
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
cette réforme ne peut pas être l'arbre
évidemment qui cache la forêt tout le
monde le reconnaît aujourd'hui la
fonction publique est mise à mal et de
très nombreux agents publics qui sont
aujourd'hui en souffrance ils sont pour
le dire
les victimes d'une politique menée
depuis des années qui tend à les
dénigrer à les stigmatiser
quand ce sont par les fonctionnaires qui
sont mis à l'index
c'est l'idée même du service public qui
est attaqué certains d'ailleurs
n'hésitent pas à considérer qu il sera
urgent d'en finir avec les services
publics existants et de concentrer les
moyens de l'état sur les seules
fonctions à cayenne limiter ainsi le
champ des services publics constitue à
l'évidence une négation de la
construction à la fois historique et
sociale de notre pays et aussi un refus
de reconnaître les besoins nouveaux de
nos concitoyens avec le considère ces
nous ne partageons pas donc l'idée selon
laquelle il y aurait aujourd'hui trop de
service public et qui serait nécessaire
pour libérer l'initiative de réduire la
dépense publique utile de diminuer le
rôle que jouent les acteurs publics en
les sacrifiant au profit du secteur
marchand il suffit de regarder partout
autour de nous d'observer les situations
dramatiques dans lesquelles vivent nos
concitoyens pour nous apercevoir nous
faut au contraire être imaginatif pour
renforcer l'efficacité des services
publics
ainsi si l'on suivait les
recommandations de ces apprentis
sorciers l'éducation nationale par
exemple ne relèverait plus d'une mission
de service public et pour la tête par
exemple confié aux collectivités
territoriales pouvoir même transférer au
privé
à l'opposé de cette logique nous sommes
pour notre part convaincu qu'il faut au
contraire renforcer et développer le
service public de l'enseignement mais
chaque collègue les services publics
demeurent aujourd'hui donc j'aurais même
tendance à le dire aujourd'hui plus que
jamais à la fois pertinent et utile
ils sont d'une certaine manière concise
il faut aussi du bouclier social
dont nous avons besoin pour faire face à
la crise pourtant la majorité
présidentielle n'a de cesse d'organiser
progressivement leur privatisation cela
prend la forme d'un transfert de
missions du public privé y compris sur
des missions présentée pourtant comme
régaliennes ainsi aujourd'hui par
exemple il ya plus d'agents privés de
sécurité que deux policiers public en
service mais cela prend aussi une autre
forme celle de la transformation des
établissements et des services publics
en de véritables entreprises
on leur impose une logique de
performance de rentabilité financière
étrangère à celle de la satisfaction des
besoins
on leur impose enfin les mêmes méthodes
de management aux entreprises privées
avec on le voit chaque jour les effets
désastreux que l'on connaît sur la santé
et les conditions de vie la réalité
cette les personnes recrutées pour
accomplir les missions publiques qui
hier étaient des fonctionnaires sont
aujourd'hui considérés comme de
véritables variable d'ajustement
conséquence la précarité gagne chaque
jour du terrain particulièrement à la
fonction publique territoriale
victime d'un double mouvement de
décentralisation et de réduction de
leurs ressources
au total s'était rappelée lioret selon
le dernier recensement
plus de 850 milles près de 900 mille
agents publics en situation précaire il
représente 16 et demi pour cent des
agents de la fonction publique
il faut dire que les employeurs publics
qui devraient pourtant être des exemples
en matière de travail de respect des
droits a juste parfois comme les pires
patrons
chacun garde en mémoire le cas de cette
postière par exemple de haute garonne
recruté par la poste des années durant
toujours en cdd
pas moins de 56 contrats successifs ou
encore celui de cette jeune femme
recrutée par l'anpe puis par pôle emploi
pendant 12 ans et toujours aujourd'hui
encore on sait dès le constat est clair
les trois versants de la fonction
publique connaissent une précarisation
jamais atteinte
et si rien n'est fait s'il n'est pas
définitivement mis un terme à cette
logique comptable mise en oeuvre alors
cette précarité
il deviendra progressivement la norme
certains à l'ump veulent d'ailleurs la
croix plus encore en proposant la fin de
la sécurité de l'emploi dans la fonction
publique
c'est dans ce contexte que nous sommes
donc appelés aujourd'hui à nous
prononcer sur ce projet de loi présenté
comme devant transposer donc l'accord
signé le 31 mars 2011 par six des huit
organisations syndicales si je me
présentais c'est le gouvernement a
profité de l'occasion pour introduire
des dispositions notamment l'équipe iii
et iv qui n'étaient pas contenus et bien
évidemment dans ce protocole d'accord et
qui n'ont pas grand chose à voir avec le
sujet pour ce qui est des dispositions
relatives à la précarité dans la
fonction publique
elles sont il faut le reconnaître pour
l'essentiel conformes au contenu du
protocole ce protocole mes chers
collègues est évidemment une étape
importante
il est le fruit d'une négociation
entamée il ya deux ans à l'initiative
des organisations syndicales
après deux ans des changes ce protocole
et par voie de conséquence ce projet de
loi est donc le fruit d'un compromis
indiscutablement ce projet de loi peut
restituer au plan individuel une réponse
à un certain nombre de situations de
précarité suivi par les agents je pense
en particulier aux agents recrutés en
cdd qui pourront donc demain bénéficier
d'un cdi
cette transformation de contrats qui
pourraient concerner donc le ministre le
rappeler environ cent mille agents est
une avancée qui pourrait en effet refusé
à ses agents aujourd'hui en situation
très précaire de pouvoir demain
bénéficier d'une meilleure sécurisation
de leur parcours professionnel
pour autant le recours comme donc le
permettre à la loi au développement des
contrats à durée indéterminée sur des
emplois permanents de la fonction
publique nous inquiète
jusqu alors assumé par des
fonctionnaires lassés des isation de ces
emplois constitue faut bien le
reconnaître une étape supplémentaire
dans le démantèlement du statut ce que
nous pouvons donc ignoré nous regrettons
aussi que les conditions de
titularisation ou de civilisation ne
permettent pas à tous les agents publics
de sortir de cette logique du précariat
je pense notamment à celles et ceux qui
a compris ses services à temps très
partiel dans une quantité inférieure à
50% et sa touche d'ailleurs très souvent
des emplois féminins
pourtant le recours au temps partiel
dans la fonction publique n'est pas une
fan une fatalité
je suis persuadé pour l'avoir
expérimenté et pour l'avoir vue d'en
avoir eu des communes le faire plus
notre gestion de l'emploi et des
carrières peut permettre d'assurer aux
agents de la réalisation d'un travail à
plein temps
mobilisant l'ensemble de leurs
compétences et leur permettant de vivre
mieux leur travail et de vivre au mieux
le fruit de leur travail par exemple
dans mon département qui compte près de
8000 agents les contractuels ne
représente que 5% des effectifs donc on
est très en deçà bien évidemment de la
moyenne nationale et pour autant mon
service fonctionne bien enfin comment ne
pas regretter que ce projet de loi ne
constitue pas un véritable plan
titularisations toutes celles et tous
ceux qui remplissent les conditions de
la titularisation ne le seront pas
puisque le nombre de postes ouverts
correspondra aux besoins recensés par
les services et non au nombre d'agents
titularisable il y à là évidemment un
manque d'ambition évident
comment pourrait-il d'ailleurs en être
autrement s'en sortir ça a été rappelé
de cette logique de la rgpp dont les
conséquences en termes d'emploi sont
désastreuses en 2013 rien dans la
fonction publique d'état
ce seront 100 mille emplois qui seront
supprimés du seul fait de l'application
de la règle de non remplacement d'un
départ à la retraite sur deux pourtant
et c'est notre conviction la pertinence
des services publics comme moyen au
service de l'intérêt général
exiger du gouvernement qu'il tutélaire
qui titularise tous les agents publics
en nous proposant donc une
titularisation très partiel vous
poursuivez donc dans la même direction
celle la réduction à tous crins de la
dépense publique
vous continuez à ne considérer les
services publics que comme des coups
alors qu'ils constituent la richesse
d'entre eux pays et qu'ils sont aussi
les investissements pour la société de
demain
du fait ces insuffisances plus des deux
tiers des agents concernés ne
bénéficierons ni de titularisation ni de
la sévérisation nous sommes donc bien
loin des précédentes opérations plan de
titularisation tels que le plan sapin ou
le plan qualité initiée en son temps par
anicet le pors
quant aux mesures destinées à endiguer à
l'avenir le recours aux emplois
contractuels
nous doutons de leur efficacité comment
pourrait il en être autrement dans la
mesure où les obligations dont il est
fait mention dans le projet de loi ne
sont suivies d'aucune sanction
de la même manière vous avez considéré
qu'il fallait permettre aux agents
recrutés en cdd dont le contrat a été
renouvelé deux fois de pouvoir prétendre
au cdi
cela est certes positif pour les agents
sans être pour autant pleinement
satisfaisant en effet certains
employeurs seront tentés de recruter
systématiquement les agents publics
différents
toujours en cdd pour accomplir une
mission qui relèverait en réalité d'un
besoin permanent sans doute aurait il
été utile de prévoir un mécanisme fondé
à la fois sur le contrat de l'agent
comme cela est le cas et sur le poste
lui même en associant mieux les
organisations syndicales notamment au
travers de comités techniques vous loyer
mes chers collègues
ce projet de loi n'est pas pour nous
pleinement satisfaisant ils auraient ils
n'oseront pas avec une conception
rabougri que nous rejetons de la
fonction publique
et c'est là d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle notre groupe a déposé de
nombreux amendements et notamment pour
rejoindre l'intervention précédente une
des interventions précédentes notamment
pour mieux prendre en compte la
situation des personnels en situation de
handicap et pour favoriser et accélérer
leur titularisation
vous considérez monsieur le ministre la
fonction publique comme un problème
comme une dépense qu'il faut contenir
nous la considérons d'autre part comme
étant un bien universel qu'il faut
consolider développer et comme une
chance entre pays
pour autant le groupe crc ne peut se
résoudre et bien évidemment
à priver les agents concernés trop peu
nombreux je le répète notre avis de
mesures qu'ils attendent
à titre personnel les organisations
syndicales ont annoncé que ce projet de
loi n'était qu'une étape et qu'elle
continuerait à se mobiliser pour sortir
tous les agents publics contractuels de
la précarité dans laquelle ils sont
enfermés et donc pour notre part bien
évidemment nous serons à leurs côtés et
nous partageons que cette analyse
raison pour laquelle le groupe crc ça
tiendra donc sur ce projet de jours
merci chers collègues la parole la
parole est à christian bourquin
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre de la fonction publique
monsieur président de la commission des
lois madame la rapporteure permettez moi
de vous saluer et de commencer mon
propos en vous apostropha remet sur le
ministre la fonction publique on peut
pas dire que vous avez bien traités les
agents de la fonction publique
durant le mandat présidentiel qui
s'achève ils sont 5 millions à avoir à
peu près le même témoignage que j'ai et
oui ils ne sont pas une variable
d'ajustement au croyez moi j'y suis à
leurs côtés - o'shea moi aussi il y a eu
madame la sénatrice beaucoup de défiance
envers les fonctionnaires de la france
ils ne sont pas qu'une variable
d'ajustement ils ne sont pas qu'un coûte
ils font ce beau métier
ce beau métier d'intérêt général qui la
règle l'intérêt général ils font ce beau
métier au service du public
ils font ce service public qu'est la
fonction publique
c'est ce que je voulais vous dire pour
pas qu'il y ait de confusion dans nos
centres d'intérêts toutefois toutefois
le caractère relativement consensuelle
du projet de loi que nous examinons ne
saurait à minimiser l'importance
le texte en effet vient modifier de
nombreux points de la législation en
vigueur concernant les recrutements et
nominations dans les trois fonctions
publiques
la fonction publique d'état la fonction
publique hospitalière et la fonction
publique territoriale
à ce titre il ne fait nul doute qu'ils
auraient mérité une deuxième et lectures
dans les deux assemblées
dans ces conditions vous comprendrez que
je déplore le choix opéré par le
gouvernement de recourir à cette
procédure accélérée
le sénat va assurément modifier ce texte
en intégrant notamment certaines
dispositions inscrites la proposition de
loi déposée par notre collègue hugues
portelli nous allons aussi être amenée à
examiner quelques amendements
gouvernementaux déposé sur le tort qui
annonce et accompagne la réforme de
l'encadrement supérieur territorial sur
laquelle depuis plus de deux ans les
services de la dgcl et dgafp travail
l'homme de ces amendements portent non
je vous reproche monsieur le ministre
votre comportement depuis cinq ans
vis-à-vis de ce que j'appelle d'intérêt
général et supérieur la richesse de la
france
mais revenons l'un de ces amendements
portent au ca y a que vous qui le dites
ici moi je le dis pas aux messieurs le
ministre revenant à l'essentiel l'un de
ces amendements portent sur le partage
en deux du cadre d'emplois des
ingénieurs territoriaux
il confie au président du centre
national la fonction publique
territoriale le cnfpt la charge de
traits de traiter la promotion interne
des cadres d'emplois supérieures à
l'échelle nationale il s'agit là de
mettre fin à une injustice qui limitait
aux plus grandes collectivités la
possibilité de cette promotion interne
d'arrêté moi monsieur le ministre de
vous alerter
cependant sur ce projet que je connais
plutôt bien étant ou en même ingénieur
territorial depuis 35 ans et ancien
administrateur du conseil
d'administration du cnfpt depuis dix ans
je vous entends plus là
les les conséquences les conséquences
pour ce dernier je veux évoquer cfdt
pour le cas où cet amendement serait
adoptée en l'état serait lourde
en effet en le chargeant le cnfpt de
l'organisation de concours et d'une
formation initiale d'un an pour les
ingénieurs en chef cfpt va devoir faire
face à de nouvelles dépenses lourdes
alors même que votre majorité monsieur
le ministre a réduit en juillet dernier
ses ressources de 10%
ici même je veux parler des ressources
du 1% de la masse salariale acquittée
par les collectivités territoriales et
vous ne pouvez pas dire que vous aimez
les la fonction publique territoriale
quand vous lui révisé son champ
d'intervention sur la formation des
agents
n'est ce pas monsieur courteau le cnfpt
est loin d'être opposé à exercer cette
nouvelle mission il s'est même préparé
en témoigne le rapport qu'il a commandé
sur la formation initiale dix élèves
ingénieurs en chef qui a été présenté à
son conseil d'administration l'année
dernière toutefois l'organisation d'un
tel concours et le financement de la
formation initiale des futurs lauréats à
lynette de strasbourg en coûte
il faut qu'on en conviennent il faut
recruter des formateurs réméré des
stagiaires prendra en charge des frais
de déplacement
or il ne vous a pas échappé
mes chers collègues y compris ceux qui
sont à ma droite que le cnfpt est vent
debout contre cette baisse de 10 % de
ses recettes adoptées avec un amendement
sénatorial
au cours de la lecture du premier projet
de loi de finances rectificative pour
cela entraîne plus tôt
réduire son offre de formation cal
augmenter le parler de ce que vous
connaissez
s'il vous plaît le président le
président du cnfpt notre collègue député
françois de luca a entrepris de
solliciter les maires et les présidents
des collectivités territoriales de
france afin qu'il fasse voter par leurs
assemblées une délibération appelant au
retour du 1% formation
monsieur ministre écoute et bienne à ce
jour il a reçu 6600 délibération de
collectivités territoriales ça doit pas
nous laisser insensible ici l'assemblée
des élus
il est rare de trouver un sujet sur
lequel au delà de tout clivage politique
les collectivités se mobilisent de la
sorte c'est même historique par ces
actes administratifs voté par leurs
assemblées délibérantes les communes
mais aussi les conseils généraux et des
conseils régionaux les établissements
publics de coopération intercommunale
marquent leur profond attachement au
service public de la formation
il en est de même pour les associations
d'élus la voix de ses élus que je devine
dominante mérite d'être entendue c'est
pour cela et au nom de nombreux
collègues
assis sur tous les bancs de cet
hémicycle à part quelques uns ici que je
vous demande de bien vouloir permettre
monsieur le ministre pour 2013 leur
établissement le rétablissement de 1% du
taux de la cotisation inscrite à
l'article 12 2 de la loi du 26 janvier
je conclurai en vous disant que à moins
de trois mois d'échéances électorales
majeures pour notre démocratie
je ne puis croire monsieur le ministre
que vous resterez insensible à la
mobilisation historique des élus locaux
mon groupe le rds au fort de quinze élus
a prévu de soutenir le projet de loi
amendé en commission en ce sens qu'il
constitue un progrès par rapport à
l'existant vous opiné du chef monsieur
le ministre vous trouvez cela bien mais
je vous invite également et surtout à
prendre en compte cette sollicitation
que j'ai tenu à porter ici à ce micro
celle de la recette de 1 % pour la
formation elle est nécessaire pour la
survie et l'avenir de nos millions
d'hommes et de femmes qui assurent ce
service publics de la fonction publique
dans nos collectivités
merci chers collègues
merci la parole est à andré reichardt
ce le président ce ministre madame le
rapporteur mes chers collègues depuis
son adoption en 1983 le statut général
de la fonction publique pose dans son
article 3 le principe sur lequel j'ouvre
les guillemets les emplois permanents
pour l'exécution du service public
administratif sont occupés par des
fonctionnaires alors même que cette
règle fait la spécificité du statut de
la fonction publique le législateur
avait déjà à l'époque admis une
dérogation en permettant le recrutement
d'agents contractuels
il est apparu très vite que le modèle
statutaire ne pourrait répondre
efficacement aux besoins de
l'administration
celle ci a toujours été amenés à
répondre à des besoins occasionnels la
conduisant à recourir à l'emploi de
contractuels la flexibilité qu'offre en
effet cette modalité de recrutement
conduit la fonction publique employés
des contractuels dans les emplois
permanents et parfois même dans le cadre
de contrats à durée indéterminée
quelques chiffres rapidement ou 31
décembre 2009 on en recensait près de
150000 dans la fonction publique d'état
200 milles dans la fonction publique
territoriale et près de 130 mis dans la
fonction publique hospitalière
la contractualisation n'est donc plus un
phénomène négligeable on l'a dit si le
succès de ce phénomène s'explique en
grande partie par son adaptabilité et sa
souplesse
il répond également au contexte de
recherche de mobilité et d'alternatives
aux modèles traditionnels
d'administration dans cette perspective
la loi du 3 août 2009 visaient à
garantir la mobilité entre les statues à
faire en sorte que l'administration
organisé offre aux agents les moyens
matériels suffisants pour la mettre en
oeuvre dans de bonnes conditions alors
de la recherche d'efficacité et
d'efficience les techniques de
management éprouvé par le secteur privé
doivent assurément être adapté aux
exigences du secteur public ces méthodes
issues du monde de l'entreprise
permettent ainsi d'enrichir l'univers de
la faune que fonction publique qui a
trop souvent souffert de critiques la
qualifiant d' ea mobile et 2
conservatrice il est donc essentiel de
passer du monde clos dans lesquelles
elle était enfermée à un univers ouvert
en outre le rapprochement entre le
secteur privé et public permettent un
apport mutuelle qui nous en sommes je
crois tous persuadés dans cette enceinte
sera bénéfique à ces deux sphères que
l'on oppose à tort trop souvent chacun
doit apprendre des expériences de l'un
et de l'autre
il faut également souligner que ça même
de la fonction publique
l'acd isation comme on dit que propose
le projet de loi permettra de mettre fin
aux disparités qui existent entre les
fonctionnaires et la situation précaire
des agents contractuels
c'est pourquoi ils étaient mes chers
collègues nécessaire de rendre les
lettres de noblesse au contrat pour
satisfaire cet objectif le gouvernement
à organiser longue phase de réflexion au
cours de laquelle différentes
consultations ont été menées ce ministre
a rappelé les différentes étapes de ce
processus
et l'on peut dire aujourd'hui que ce
projet de loi est le fruit d'un grand
long effort de recherche de consensus
parmi les acteurs sociaux ce dont le
groupe ump
bien entendu se félicite il tient compte
des difficultés concrètes face auquel
les agents contractuels sont confrontés
quotidiennement aujourd'hui la fonction
publique désire jouer à armes égales
avec le secteur privé pour se
positionner en véritable acteur du
système économique
le contrat a longtemps été décrié car il
était signe de précarité mais il
s'agissait davantage d'une situation
incertaine qui résultaient de l'emploi
de contrat à durée déterminée que de la
forme contractuelle en elle-même
l'emploi du contrat à durée déterminée
est utile à l'administration pour
répondre à des besoins occasionnels
par contre lorsqu'il s'agit de besoins
permanents
il est nécessaire de passer à des
contrats à durée indéterminée
voilà donc pour l'examen de ce projet de
loi destiné à réduire la précarité dans
la fonction publique
c'était la discussion générale autour de
ce texte qui est en procédure accélérée
c'est à dire qu'il n'y aura qu'une seule
lecture dans chaque assemblée les
députés examinent ans
le texte à partir du 7 février prochain
merci de nous avoir suivi sur public
sénat toute petite place à l'info
politique et parlementaire avec le 19
heures présenté par michel grossiord